like it really is that simple if
anybody's been through a journey of
getting into better physical health like
if you've never worked out and you
haven't eat well that first workout is a
disaster I did it at 38 like you can't
do my eight push-ups were a
disaster the treadmill was a disaster
like when I think back to that workout
10 years ago I'm like my God but I had
to start there to be able to do things
I'm doing today it's like riding a bike
you needed training wheels the first
time you tried to swim you almost died
you know like like it's just like your
first kiss was not phenomenal I promise
you you know and so same here you've got
to really really really just start and
you can't be scared of it what's going
to happen who's going to make fun of you
like do it in the privacy of your own
home but figure start figuring it
out